Hanscom breasts - do you ever feel like
you don't have motivation
do you ever feel like you need some help
to get things done well I got just a
solution for you
[Music]
motivational game
hello and welcome to the motivational
challenge here are you gonna create a
lot in your life and just live in peace
you ready okay challenge 1 clicky in the
button for 240 times before the time
runs app you are not responsible for any
damage caused to your mass or your hand
just do it
nothing is impossible okay okay there's
a timer oh my god 205 thanks shy up oh I
got a click double hand [ __ ] trying
240 I didn't even get 200
the [ __ ] shame on me again I don't know
it's impossible I mean nothing is
impossible
oh my god it was I was I was looking
outside the button it's impossible
Shia you're here can I touch you no I
will try again
[Music]
that was [ __ ] intense man challenged
to press any key to do it okay and touch
I know I can
it's going on its life I did not live it
[Music]
okay three
hi-oh
O'Shea poor sorry five man I'm good at
this
what is going on can okay the life you
make you make so many decisions Shia
LaBeouf is alumina yep or nah nah
what is the name of this game
League of Legends for beta minecraft
Shia mod that yeah I think that was said
right
or was it Titanic or wasn't motivational
game click anyone okay click anyone
again okay and they now don't click ok
click anyone yeah upgrade yourself to
the next challenge
some speed some speed I don't need MP
and attack and dexter it and we're done
this is not an MMO CH well I'm sorry the
[ __ ] are you on about Travolta's lost up
and find your home got a god this is a
right go right Walter dead-end street
sorry room what the [ __ ] am I looking at
yes I'm Welsh I okay go left Travolta
corner Street alright keep going [ __ ]
where are you Oh God keep going bruh
find the UFO what are you gonna do face
the truth Travolta is beginning to be
abducted oMG oh my god
oh my god we're witnessing this live
very first on the put wait it was a
dream Travolta is confused
I like his wallpaper [ __ ] I will Shayla
bare right all right keep going keep
going
face the truth oh my god oh wait night
oh oh [ __ ] then go left again you find
your home congratulations wait I heard
something inside your house
just completely change please are you
sure yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes yes
yes yes yeah okay fine
goddammit God [ __ ] you [ __ ] you please
yes yes yes yes yes [ __ ] yeah okay yes
[Music]
oh yes UK uh read it this is the letter
for Tripoli
I'm excited babe wolf you're a lush
right I'm happy just reading section
okay so go left left
now wait ten seconds and click the
window of your house
okay so left left cool complete
challenge just complete okay so left
left
you've cool complete challenge just
complete challenge now we wait ten
seconds
[Music]
left window which left window right holy
[ __ ] I got him first strike damn I was
really [ __ ] fast one night science
impressed by their motivation but damn
it oh my god what now wait the
Illuminati is challenging you to a race
press the keys to win click to do it
[Music]
[Applause]
what am I looking at I don't
oh god Illuminati is winning come on
Shia come on you gotta beat daddy I
never figured this heard him laugh no no
we're gonna [ __ ] your lemon on it I'm
gonna [ __ ] you can't do it I can't do it
Shia oh my god alright we're gonna have
to put that your way again
hey I'm sorry
my child go go child the King all right
[Music]
now
oh wow
suck on that Illuminati suck on these
[Music]
yeah yeah [ __ ]
that's right I knew it I had it in me
all alone
[Music]
congratulation you learned something I
did learn so much we learned so much
determination hard but we did it trust
trust was there you blessing me with
your motivational you help me throw and
make decisions with your face and your
speech and traveled I'll never forget
your courage troubles aliens I don't
know why alien was there but he was and
it was beautiful now you are in peace
I am indeed in peace I'm crying I'm
crying real tears real Cheers
[Music]
and that was our score thank you for
watching
motivational game look like if you
enjoyed it and I'll see you bro soon
hell it's always stay awesome bros haha
make it stop who came up with this idea